thank you
[Music]
all right there's a Texas man he buys
this run down home
I felt like this was a typo but I don't
think it is he bought this rundown
three-bedroom home in Texas for sixteen
thousand dollars it's possible okay
where and he discovers something in his
yard it's probably not a major city yeah
because there's like Texas so Bailey got
Houston Dallas 720 whatever it's
probably like two hours away and then
you get Oklahoma prices yeah
here you go this was his backyard so
it's kind of like crappy she was in a
bat hitting the backyard dude honestly
those are some Pelosi Heavies it's the
below they got some there's a man's your
hormones distract your eyes hey let's
just check this story out real quick can
we scroll over [ __ ] the yard for a
second we gotta keep its Bridal ass we
gotta get to the bottom all right look
here you go check this yard out I I
don't want to find something in this
yard
that's pretty cool buried treasure
marijuana what do you think it is
marijuana I'm gonna guess it's all
marijuana it's not a plant looks like a
basilgar it looks like a little planter
it's not marijuana
by the way that's a big what do you
think what would as a homeowner what
would you like to find in your boggy
green overgrown yard [ __ ] a ton of
[ __ ] crypto wallets full of Bitcoin
Berry crypto wallet they're not that's
not how it works you don't bury your
ledgers okay they're on the blockchain
dude as a homeowner maybe like there's a
trap door and then when you open the
trap door you have like way more real
estate in a basement uh situation like
Dungeons that's close full dungeons
bomb shelter sick stuff inside yes with
John Goodman in it and it's that one
movie that's really cool yes I thought
you were talking about he goes into a
[ __ ] Bruce Wayne like Batcave oh yeah
yes that that's better talking about
that John Goodman was just a throw-off
okay well that's cool but uh if you
thought more realistically you would
come out with something like this after
moving all that [ __ ] he had a giant ass
pool sick and jacuzzi it wasn't listed
on any of the information oh wow dude
you know what that means this guy got
sick of having a pool I'll tell you what
it's a maintenance nightmare this guy
wanted a skate Parker is that how you
feel now now that you have a pool I'll
tell you what run this bit go ahead let
me tell you something about having a
pool guess what what you got to take
care of it oh yeah it's great having a
pool yeah we're in pool parties every
night you don't first of all you don't
second of all if all your neighbors have
a pool everyone kind of uses their own
pool and like there's no real pool
parties anymore
so now pool parties is a fallacy yeah so
now what do you do you just sit there
and oh [ __ ] I gotta maintain this [ __ ]
every month oh no God this is gonna be
crazy so now you start going to Home
Depot buying spider plants
spider plants yeah empty your pool you
start filling it up with this [ __ ] and
then you just tell everyone I don't even
I don't I don't have a pool that's a
backyard because you want to be
different yeah well no it's just that
you don't have to take care of the pool
anymore it's [ __ ] 100 maintenance how
much does it cost typically to take care
of a pool hundreds of hundreds of
dollars a month how much does it cost to
buy that many spider plants it's way
cheaper than a hundred dollars one time
it's a good propagate
you take a little piece of the spider
plant and you put it in a little jar
with water and that becomes its own
spider plant now all of a sudden you
spend 30 on a spider plant you have
three thousand square yeah you got all
your spider plants you know all your
spider plants looking at each other like
this
just so cocky
which spotted plants the original
planting jars plants you are [ __ ] Dr
cocky propagator so check this out after
a little let down that it's not a bat
cave but that's just me but this is
actually tight after some Rehabilitation
check it out
this is a happy story this is a before
picture he didn't he didn't scrub that
part as hard that's right I'm spicy yeah
it's kind of dirty and I'm proud of that
part yeah yeah what the [ __ ] this looks
[ __ ] up
those are the spider plants he couldn't
get out yeah he's not entered into
[ __ ] pageant guys you know what's
pretty dope though so a pool can cost
like 50 to 80 G's just the uh cool part
not even like the Landscaping so that's
like coming like finding 50 to 80.
that's the pull part not the Landscaping
so like if you were to build a backyard
right like you have plants you have to
pour concrete for the sidewalk you might
have like a little planter and like
little steps and stuff that's all
considered Landscaping the actual pool
part is just the hole in the ground and
then either the plaster or the tile that
covers it that holds the water and that
whole process could be 50 to like 80.
you had to redo the vast majority of it
but you have to Red dig the hole which
is it cost around like eight grand to
fix and repair everything but estimated
if there was no pool there and he wanted
to get one made it would be almost like
170k in the whole backyard too yeah yeah
cost more than his [ __ ] house or do
you have a pool now no we don't even
have a house we don't have a pool
Steve does I got a pool I've had a pool
for way long he doesn't even want me
anymore
the fake ones pool parties all the time
I don't need it fake spider plants yeah
fake spider plants we're gonna find out
how much a fake spider plant costs 170
Grand oh dude 12 bucks I'm getting
[ __ ] left the real ones so it ranges
from 1255 to 84 bucks
yeah so how many do you think you need
to fill a pool six feet deep minimum in
Vegas
now six to eight so so now you're
talking about like five probably forty
one thousand one thousand Jesus Christ
you're looking at you're ruined and they
all go like this
you're looking at three 3.4 million
dollars in spider plants what was it
worth
oh my God
my kids are [ __ ]
I should have just bought concrete
put my pool in so yeah after uh
after all the rehab he did on his yard
and the whole house in general it is now
worth around like 180k whoa wow but he
said he doesn't want to sell it
um initially was going to buy it as a
flipper and now he's just Gonna Keep It
In Living he just likes enough I don't
know what he did he's waiting until he
starts realizing how much of a pain in
the ass that pool maintenance is telling
you the house guys are Jay did he does
he doesn't get it yet he doesn't know it
starts great
honeymoon phase when's the last time you
guys looked like this in your own home
he looks happy eon
[Laughter]
our backyard's really Barren that's the
problem I think I saw a pretty cool
trash can it's gone now I have to throw
it away trash can my wife made me throw
it away but I liked it it came with the
house you just got to put stuff in it or
what is it we gotta shove stuff into it
yeah so look you saw my neighbors right
palm trees cool lights palm trees cool
lights our house like concrete chipped
paint pool and I'm like great we look
like [ __ ] like we're the guys like
you know when you look in your
neighbor's yard and you're like
where are those guys where it's like our
yard looks tight and then like over here
it's like but you got the fun Flamingo
floaty in there it's fun but it's Sun
bleached now bro cause it's 100 goddamn
18 degrees every day I thought I thought
you were trying to convince us to move
there why telling you wait wait wait
which video are we in
switch mode
I'm Tony dude the Sun hits
shift gears dude the Sun hits every part
of your [ __ ] body in Vegas no matter
where you are from July well well yeah
late June
to now even it's still 105 today was it
yeah it's not don't look it up
this campaign is losing steam dude
I think it's like I think it's a 90
right now but still it's like what the
[ __ ] it's October that's cooling down
mid-october yeah so apparently according
to the U.S Geological Survey which has
nothing to do with this meteological
survey November
November 15th is when Vegas really
really really cools down and then we get
like four months of cool before it's
time to turn up the burners again what
do you do in that time like how do you
maximize enjoyment I put on winter
Parkers and stuff and I go ice skating
on your frozen pool no luckily oh wow
this is all kinds of options yeah the
winter scene is pretty cool because it
actually gets cold so it's actually like
scarf and jacket weather yeah is your
pool gonna freeze no sick
you can keep putting spider plants in
there hey I thought I thought it was
full of [ __ ] floaties it's chocolate
floaties but we're gonna we have to um
compromise yeah we'll have to figure it
out yeah
you know every time I'm taking out my
trash I'm like man if I fall in this
pool
like during during the winter months too
you're like I'll [ __ ] probably die
instantly it's so cold outside it's
actually cold
it's actually cold instantly okay it's
like cool because I disintegrate I got
[ __ ] fight on the west coast for too
long like I lived there for like [ __ ]
you know how old am I now how much for
that 37 I think I moved to West Coast
when I was like 13. it's like holy [ __ ]
it is you get spoiled egg you get so
spoiled and then like you just feel a
little bit cold water like oh no and so
that's where I'm at right now yeah
versus like the East Coasters are like
jogging when it's snowing outside
exactly you know so that's cool I mean
at least you won't get randomly stabbed
out there
laughs
[Music]